(crowd yelling)
- [Reporter] The Supreme Court
has overturned Roe V. Wade,
the 1973 decision that
established a constitutional right
to an abortion in the US.
- [Crowd] Roe V. Wade has got to go!
- [Crowd] My body, my choice!
- [Reporter] Now decisions
on the legality of abortion
are left to the states.
- This is going to mean
that access to abortion
will vary dramatically,
depending on where you live.
- [Reporter] While 16 states
and the District of Columbia
have laws that protect
the right to an abortion.,
22 states have laws that could
ban all or most abortions
now that Roe has been reversed,
according to the Guttmacher Institute,
a policy group that
supports abortion rights
and tracks national abortion statistics.
The organization details
a patchwork of laws
among these states, including
pre-Roe bans, trigger laws,
and post-Roe restrictions
that will determine the fate
of abortion access in the US.
- The resolution passes.
(gavel bangs)
- [Reporter] Nine states
have bans on their books
that predate Roe V. Wade,
which have been unenforceable
for the past five decades.
- Some of them date back to
the late 1800s or early 1900s.
These could be laws that could be enforced
after this decision or as
a result of this decision.
- [Reporter] States like Arkansas
can now revive their Pre-Roe bans
through official enforcement
or by filing court actions.
However, not all states with Pre-Roe bans
are poised to enforce the laws.
(crowd cheers)
Michigan Governor Gretchen Whitner
and abortion rights
groups have filed lawsuits
to block the state's 1931 law
that makes providing an abortion
at any point during pregnancy a felony.
A Michigan judge, through
a preliminary injunction,
said the state can't enforce it.
- Whereas others in states
like Arizona, for example,
I know lawmakers there are anticipating
that they could enforce their
own pre-Roe ban on abortion.
- [Reporter] 13 states have
passed so-called trigger laws
on the condition they would go into effect
if the Supreme court rescinded
the constitutional right to abortion.
- However, each of these
laws are quite different
from the other one.
- [Reporter] And they can take
effect at different times.
In Kentucky, Louisiana, and South Dakota,
the laws are enforceable immediately,
but in Texas, Idaho, and Tennessee,
there's a 30-day buffer
period between Roe's reversal
and when the laws go into effect.
In some states, trigger
laws can only be implemented
after state government officials,
such as Attorneys General or Governors,
certify the high court's decision.
Some states, including
Georgia and Alabama,
have sought to set stricter limits
on when abortions can be
performed during a pregnancy.
Georgia's ban on abortion
around when cardiac
activity can be detected
and Alabama's near-total ban
have previously been blocked in court
because they conflicted
with limits set by Roe.
- Now the elimination of
thee federal protections
for the procedure and the reversal
of the Supreme Court precedent
means that it's possible
they can be resurrected in some way.
- [Crowd] Save our babies!
- [Reporter] Some states don't have
these specific restrictions
or protections for abortion
currently on the books
and it remains to be seen
what actions they will take in the future.
Meanwhile, abortion clinics
in more liberal states
have been preparing for
an influx of patients.
- They are expanding their
hours, adding more staff,
adding more days that they are available
to accommodate what they expect
to be even more patients coming in.
- [Reporter] Abortion providers
in more restrictive states
are also assessing how to support patients
who will need to travel
outside of the state
for the procedure.
- Planning and figuring out
how they will navigate this different
and varying access to
abortion across this country
will be something that I'm
sure will take some time
to really nail down and figure out.
- [Speaker] What do we do?
- [Crowd] Hands off, fight back!